Speaker 1: Next debate that we looked at Marjorie
Taylor GREENE versus challenger Marcus Flowers.
This one is like nothing I have ever, ever
seen.
First and foremost, Marjorie Taylor GREENE
accuses one of the journalists on the panel
of being a Democrat activist, so-called, because
of a question he asked.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 5: And we need to.
What can you tell me?
Give me an example.
Speaker 4: No, you do this every time we have
a debate.
Where you at?
Speaker 1: I ask a question.
It's obvious.
Speaker 4: You're like, what?
You mean you were kicked off of here committees
for saying things were controversial.
You've apologized for controversial statements,
right?
Those types of things.
What is your process for fact checking and
vetting the things that you say in public?
Speaker 5: I the things I say in public are
the truth.
And that's why they're so offensive to Democrat
activists in the media.
Just like you.
Speaker 1: Notice how that's not an answer?
That's not.
Well, here's how I. FactCheck.
No, it's you're a Democrat activist for even
asking.
Speaker 5: That, and you're asking me a blanket
question with no example.
I stand by the things that I say.
I stand by.
Speaker 1: And she stands by it.
Whatever it is, she stands by it.
And of course, she said some horrible things.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE flips out when her
opponent, Marcus Flowers, accuses her of fomenting
the sentiment that led to January six by pushing
election big lie stuff.
And then he tries to pin her down as to whether
Joe Biden won.
She refuses to answer.
She says only that Joe Biden is the president.
This is really embarrassing.
Speaker 4: To almost to a person has said
Marjorie Taylor GREENE is not who they want
representing them.
So, yes, this campaign is about Marcus flowers
not not mtg.
Thank you for what.
Speaker 5: You talked about.
I need a rebuttal to that.
You cannot accuse me of insurrection.
I was a victim of the January six riot just
as much as any other member of Congress.
That was the third day I had on the job.
I had nothing to do with what happened there
that day, and I will not have you accuse me
of that.
That is wrong of you to do your line about
me and you will not defame my character in
that manner.
Speaker 4: Did Joe Biden win the election?
Speaker 5: Congresswoman GREENE Joe Biden
is the president of the United States.
Speaker 1: Understand that.
That's how they avoid it.
They say he is the president, but they won't
say he won.
Speaker 4: Absolutely.
But you pushed a big lie.
They said he did not win the election.
Speaker 5: There was.
And since I.
Speaker 4: Drove those people to the Capitol
on January six, you're lying.
Speaker 5: We're going to move on.
Josh Roe, it's your turn to fight.
And my husband has to.
Speaker 1: He's my husband has proof.
That's another one of the lies she's been
telling.
Marcus Flowers is really good, and sadly,
I don't think he stands a chance from the
little polling I've seen.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE was asked, What's the
accomplishment you're most proud of?
And she basically says, Democrats haven't
let me do anything, but I got some grants.
Speaker 4: And your question for Marjorie
Taylor.
Speaker 3: GREENE Ms.. GREENE Since taking
office on January 3rd, 2021, what is the one
specific accomplishment solely on behalf of
the 14th Congressional District that is most
important to you?
Speaker 5: Well, I tell you what, it's been
hard to pass any bills and a Democrat controlled
Nancy Pelosi controlled House of Reps to.
Speaker 1: Real that real personal responsibility.
I couldn't do anything because of the Democrats.
Speaker 5: And it is a Senate that is controlled
by one vote with Kamala Harris as.
Speaker 1: Kamala.
Speaker 5: The Democrat vice president and
a White House that is controlled by by Democrats,
Joe Biden.
Now, what we've done to accomplish things
for northwest Georgia is I'm proud to be able
to bring in money via grants to help our local
sheriff's department and help local businesses
there.
We've also worked very hard with the flooding
that happened over in summer.
Bill Somerville And so we've worked hand in
hand with officials there and look forward
to helping them more as damages and amounts
of money come out.
So I'm very excited to to vote and to introduce
bills that uphold the conservative tradition,
traditional values of the people in my district
and I'll.
Speaker 1: Even her grin seems to suggest
she knows this is B.S..
Speaker 5: Continue to do that.
All right, Josh.
Speaker 4: You get the final question.
Did you have a rebuttal?
Yeah, I didn't hear the answer there.
Ladies and gentlemen, Representative Green
said she's passed all these bills and brought
money into our district.
Well, you haven't.
Speaker 5: You know, I've never heard of Joe
Biden.
Speaker 4: Come into our.
Speaker 1: Dinner.
Okay.
Anyway, so just a complete and total disaster.
One more segment here, Marcus Flowers, actually,
a couple did.
This was really interesting.
Marcus Flowers asked Marjorie Taylor GREENE,
why did she seem to care more about the insurrectionists
than people in her district?
And she did not like that.
Speaker 4: You know, you spent your time in
Congress these last couple of years providing
aid and comfort to the January six insurrectionists.
My question for you is why do you care more
about those criminals in jail than you do
about the people of our district?
Speaker 5: You want to know something I care
about?
About stopping the two tiered justice system
that is happening right now in America.
Speaker 1: Which she thinks is Trumpists and
everyone else.
But the real two tiered justice system is
the privileged and elite and everybody else.
Speaker 5: I was a victim of the January six
riot, and I've said it over and over again.
I'm completely against what happened on January
six, but I will not stand by and watch Merrick
Garland turn the Department of Justice into
a political weapon and the FBI sending it
after parents that are addressing their school
boards, people that walked in the Capitol
and have been held in jail for nearly two
years while Antifa and BLM riots rioters go
free are never held accountable.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, that's not true.
And the hilarity of a Republican suddenly
caring about.
Pretrial detention is really, really quaint.
Last clip she does pull out the Q and on stuff
pedophilia, child abuse, etc..
Speaker 5: Party.
The Democrat Party is the party of child abuse.
It's the party that represents screaming children
and sexualizing them in school, teaching anti-white
racism in the terms of CRT education and genital
mutilation of kids.
Kids that can't even get a driver's license,
can't get a tattoo and cannot vote.
How do you stand there and represent the Democrat
Party as a father?
And do you believe in genital mutilation,
mutilation of children under the age of 18
and these puberty blockers that have severe
health consequences.
Rep.
Speaker 1: So it really buzzword.
Q And on bingo there for Marjorie Taylor GREENE
she sadly will probably win and that says
more about the country than it does about
Marcus Flowers, who is an excellent candidate.
We'll take a quick break and then look at
the Ron Johnson Mandela Barnes interview right
after this.